é boa noite primeiramente gostaria de
agradecer a oportunidade
sou ela então vi lá do rio de janeiro e
eu gosto de funk se
é o título da palestra eu pensei muito
ao longo da semana eu acho que é uma
coisa que acredito muito e acredito
muito na nossa nação acredito muito no
brasil então é no brasil que eu quero
viver e eu vou começar a palestra
perguntando pra vocês vocês se tem idéia
de onde vai estar o brasil em 2050
alguém tem idéia de como estará o brasil
mas alguém acredita que em 2050 já está
casado com filhos
será que os pais de vocês pra galera
mais jovem ainda esperam para presente
na vida de vocês acompanhando a
trajetória mais ou menos em 2050
a média de idade que for a galera que
nasceu na década de 1990 nós teremos
entre 50 e 65 anos
é o que mostram as pesquisas a pirâmide
etária mostra que tende a se inverter a
pirâmide então ou seja nós teremos mais
pessoas mais velhas do que pessoas mais
jovens
então essa é a última geração aqui no
brasil e nós temos com a população jovem
muito mais extensa do que o do que uma
população mais velha e que a gente tira
com relação a isso
você vê que eles pensassem e três
segundos que se realmente nós assumimos
o protagonismo de começar a mudar nossa
geração agora o negócio vai ficar um
pouco complicado certo será que a gente
vai continuar terceirizando a
responsabilidade de deixar pra lá
aquelas pessoas que estão em brasília a
mudança que a gente realmente quer ver
fiquei realmente sonha em transformar o
país e continuar vivendo aqui a gente
tem que começar a fazer alguma coisa com
relação a dados econômicos continua
continuaremos estagnados na sétima maior
economia do mundo se não tiver nada
revolucionário também se a gente não
continuar fazendo besteira né porque aí
o negócio vai ficar mais complicado
então
e minha missão aqui hoje é simplesmente
garantir que vocês vão sair daqui hoje
com o propósito de ajudar a melhorar
esse país vindos com a gente ou relação
a isso eu gostaria de começar falando um
pouco sobre a minha família eu acho que
muito da consciência que eu tenho hoje
sobre trajetória é fugir dessas pessoas
ali têm uma foto minha na minha
formatura com meu pai minha mãe meu
irmão minha família meus pais separados
desde que eu tinha quatro anos de idade
meu pai voltará muito presente na nossa
educação e aqui está a minha mãe e minha
tia que eu considero que eu tive dentro
de casa no mesmo quintal três mães me
ensinar valores muito importante
acho que o principal deles a questão de
honestidade mas me ensinaram muita tatá
as pessoas com respeito e educação de
trato na educação que a gente aprende
aqui na universidade aquela educação que
você sabe valorizar desde a pessoa que é
o porteiro até o reitor dessa
instituição não tem muito orgulho dela
ter mostrado isso com meu pai eu aprendi
muito no valor do trabalho eu ele quando
tinha oito anos de idade meu irmão tinha
11 ele fez uma proposta pra gente e nos
levou numa praia ele é padeiro e minha
mãe técnico em saúde bucal e fez um
desafio vou dar um dinheiro pra vocês eu
vou colocar uma barraca aqui tem pessoas
que vão vender junto comigo se vocês
quiserem se podem vender aqui próximo da
barraca ea lucratividade de vocês
a experiência foi muito bacana porque
nós conseguimos vender o meu irmão mas
para a sociedade conseguimos ganhar uma
grana bacana e depois liguei pro meu
irmão eu falei cara você não tem nela
vamos vender mais caro tomar sol ele
falou tipo não é letal se tá maluca
chegou uma quantidade em dinheiro um
pouco mais conservador
aí eu fui lá e vencer sozinho aquilo que
foi três vezes mais
eu vou ter essa experiência com oito
anos de idade pra casa de saquarema para
são gonçalo que é onde ele foi nascido e
criado querendo vender tudo inclusive a
minha mãe então passei a vender a
bolinha de gude na porta de casa você
vender um sacolé picolé e de tantas
coisas e com meu irmão ele sempre foi
referência pra mim dentro de casa embora
ninguém nenhum deles tenha tido é ensino
superior
com relação à educação o que a gente
espera
sobre educação e esse foi um exemplo era
o tipo melhores alunos da escola sempre
só que na vida é aquilo que a vida é
feita de ciclos e esses ciclos é é hora
tem início meio e fim sempre nas coisas
ea nossa base quem nós somos hoje não é
nós somos frutos daquilo que vivemos
fizemos e aquilo que nós idealizamos no
passado e para isso realmente eu acho
que ao longo da vida dessa caminhada eu
ganhei alguns presentes de deus que eu
tenho várias outras famílias espalhadas
em outros lugares
eu não poderia deixar de falar que hoje
um pouquinho deles também
primeiro ele um marcos mono esse cara eu
vou falar um pouco mais à frente mas
adiantando um pouquinho ele foi um cara
que quando tinha 16 anos de idade eu fui
numa palestra no planejamento de vida e
carreira no dia 30 de junho de 2011 e
tipo de status legal na palestra foi bem
posso te mandar meio pós aí
procrastinação e depois de três meses
não mandei pra ele tem mota palestra com
ele fui lá de novo ele falou eu
desconheço em que demandam e meia me
mandou e mail e jo eu era garoto eu
falei pô vou mandar email para o cara
pedindo orientação de carreira com a
história da minha vida
mandou eu ir pra ele de 10 página e é
neste ano e que sei no corpo do e-mail
só que eu garante que o início seria
interessante
ali o primeiro parágrafo ele vai
continuar lendo e e foi o que aconteceu
ele me ligou e pediu pra pra tomar um
café comigo no hotel em copacabana para
quem conhece são gonçalo é do outro lado
da ponte é bem longe ele falou perto da
sua casa e falei pô é bem perto fica
tranquilo eu tô aí nem como nem dormir é
para não chegar atrasado e ele como foi
diretor de a unilever a quatro bancos
santander dentre outras empresas já vejo
possibilidade de poder te ajudar e se
tornou um segundo pai para mim
eu acho que hoje grande parte do que eu
gosto de fazer depois que esse cara eu
encontrei com ele é graças a muita
orientação muita conversa e paciência
que ele tem comigo e essa segunda
família equipe
eu acho que um pouco mais velho eu tive
a oportunidade de conviver durante um
ano numa casa o botafogo é uma família
linda que eles não adotaram literalmente
como se fosse filho
saí de são gonçalo para estudar na
cidade do rio de janeiro e eles por ter
se envolvido com o petróleo mas tomará
na arábia saudita a escócia méxico é
frança estados unidos e nesse um ano que
eles ficaram 3 no rio durante um ano com
vivi lá então lá eu tive a oportunidade
de conviver literalmente no la mas assim
eu falei com vocês que 88 anos de idade
tive essa experiência mas o que foi
realmente um divisor de águas na minha
vida que me faz de repente eu acho que a
galera me convidar para estar aqui hoje
porque os 12 anos eu comecei a vender
picolé dentro de um batalhão de polícia
mas como assim o garoto vem de picolé do
batalhão de polícia eu meu pai abri uma
padaria e chamou a gente para trabalhar
de novo e eu juntei uma grana e com essa
grana eu comecei com dano ao negócio da
da fábrica de doces já comecei
fornecendo 22 para continuar uma igreja
hoje um ano e meio era de 22 a 23
lugares que nós fornecíamos de 5 850 mil
12 por semana eu pagava tinha pra fazer
tomava conta da produção ea mãe não
tinha mais cozinha e era assim que
começar a ganhar dinheiro os 12 anos de
idade e só que enquanto negócio do doce
nuno alavancava falei porque eu posso
fazer é um belo dia eu sair na rua e
estava muito calor e tudo mais depois da
escola eu falei é de vez em quando
vendia picolé com um amigo que a mãe
dele tinha um salão de cabeleireiro
falei pô vou vender é picolé na verdade
que vendia era eu saí pra vender a idc
outras pessoas perguntaram que tenha foi
o tempo que o lap collet que coco
morango abacaxi milho verde lançada a
graviola acerola e custo real
e aí nesse dia eram três policiais dois
capitães um major falou comigo aí foram
chupando aí na hora de receber falará
que se precisa é preciso receber a gente
está sem dinheiro que vamos lá que você
vai vender muito a lei dissipada levar
para dentro do 7º batalhão de polícia
militar em são gonçalo e um vídeo com
ela durante três anos no primeiro dia
que eu vendi procura lá eu vendi mais ou
menos 90 picolés eu comprava 45 centavo
e vendiam real eu for mal salário mínimo
lá em 2007 início em 2007 eu ganhava só
de venda de picolé dois salários mínimos
de uma hora até dos dois meses a taxa
que só vendia do batalhão e com um meio
de troca de comando comando caiu tudo
mais trocaram houveram álbum
as mudanças e achou um coronel um
chamado ricardo quemento lobasso que
falou isso pra mim muito bacana você
vende aqui tem aqui o pessoal aqui da
dados oficiais pedindo para você
continuar vendendo você estuda falar
estudo a legal se estuda é mesma coisa
que tira notas boas falei pô eu tiro
tudo mas tal não fazer um combinado se
você vai continuar vendo aqui se todo
final de mérito que você gosta seu
boletim
eu não queria perder o dinheiro né e tal
falei pô vou continuar e para isso minha
mãe falou pra mim algumas vezes nesse
processo aí o primeiro mês nós você
nunca mais voltar aqui no local porque
literalmente lá só tem pessoas que mais
velhas pessoas que matam as outras
pessoas é um ambiente muito o chievo e
tal eu pensando por minha mãe
tirando o meu sonho de ficar rico é o
quando trabalhava na padaria do meu pai
uma semana grava 50 reais aqui eu ganho
uma hora e meia num dia e aí foi assim
que começaram a surgir algumas coisas da
minha vida aí pra polícia militar e lá
eu acho que ele me ensinar valores muito
muito bacanas como ser um cara sério
pela disciplina montar a estratégia para
a vida tenha como foco militar sabe que
tem coisas realmente hierarquia às vezes
é muito complexo tal de se entender mas
tem valores muito muito bons e depois
disso a inter pensa né com 12 anos 13 14
15 anos vendendo picolé do batalhão de
polícia muito bacana as pessoas que
admiram as pessoas olhar o pelezinho
tudo mais alto que o nosso filho mascote
do batalhão
só que chegou um momento que você pára
até quando vou ficar vendo com ela minha
vida foi quando eu passei por essa
escola que do meio da escola técnica
aqui passei em quarto lugar e falei cara
tem começa a cortar a meta na minha vida
estava vendo mesmo em ano de vestibular
e um ano antes eu tinha conseguido uma
bolsa de 50% eu pagava o restante dos
corais tinham conseguido que foi uma
experiência fantástica porque era
trabalhar estudar para poder pagar a
escola e no meio do ano tive o
descolamento do ápice da cabeça femoral
escolheu o filme da bacia ea escola que
arcou com os dez mil reais cirurgia
então acho que na vida nada acontece por
acaso tinha saído da escola pública e
ter lá pelo menos acredito muito em deus
uma outra coisa que minha mãe me ensinou
muito a ter fé
então acho que esse ano tudo deu certo
entre essa escola
o aluno havia uma bolsa pela embaixada
americana e aí todo mundo na escola
queria fazer engenharia de alimentos e
descobri que não era isso que eu queria
fazer o que você quer fazer então fa
finanças armas finanças aonde economia
administração aí eu comecei a me dedicar
a conhecer cooke e beck fgv
e aí descobri mec foi depois da nec é
muito bacana posso fazer e me com um
foco muito no mercado financeiro
para quem não conhece uma faculdade do
rio de janeiro muito tradicional nessa
área de mercado financeiro e na área de
finanças né e três federais estão muito
boas mas apurímac fgv lá no rio está com
bastantes faculdades privadas
e foi assim que no terceiro ano do
ensino médio após conhecer aquele senhor
que eu falei nisso bairros bola e falou
que havia a possibilidade de poder te
ajudar e que acha que está na escola
chamada escola parque na época era a 13ª
melhor escola do estado do rio
filho de muitos artistas dava poucas
bolsas foi lá fez uma prova conseguir e
fui estudar só o terceiro ano e aí com
três meses era muito complicado em
voltado são gonçalo sala 50 a 70 km/h
nosso bizarro 244 b pegará o ônibus sete
horas na escola de 75 depois chegar no
caso 1886 e é uma das professoras minha
conversando com ela falou a mesma e
diretora da escola pública na zona sul o
que você acha que você fica lá eu falei
pô bacana isso hein
mas como assim né falei bacana no
sentindo de pouco continua falando e eu
falei pô meio absurdo que vai dormir
numa escola pública e tal
só que quando falou absurdo eu espero
terminar de falar e depois eu reflito
para depois dar um parecer
foi quando eu cheguei em casa já falando
com a minha mãe que eu domino a escola
pública e passei a dormir na sala dos
professores num sofá cama na escola
pública próxima da nossa escola privada
escola parque e consegui a bolsa e eu
acho que depois da tempestade sempre vem
a bonança e consegui passar na puc no
hermético bolsa é é parceira federal
para estadual tirei meu na redação do
enem
então acho que as conquistas de um ano
foram bem expressivos e chegou em 2013
eu já tava em mente ter algumas coisas
que queria ter uma experiência
internacional não está aqui mas eu fui
para a opção com bolsa e t associação de
assistência ao adolescente é uma
associação que ajuda bastante o
potencial foi foi a galera
cursos e uma coisa que estava muito na
minha mente era tipo fundação estudar
não ser que alguém com essa fundação
estudar aqui é bacana e eu não quis
submeter para a seletiva em 2013 porque
eu achava que literalmente é eu já
estava com muita bolsa nelson caçador de
bolsas a itown fico sempre pesquisando e
isso que eu entendi que eu pudesse
ajudar é muito baixo que o de ajuda
financeira para pagar minha faculdade
que tinha bolsa que a rede era muito
forte
foi quando em 2015 ou subjetivo o
processo seletivo da fundação estudar e
graças a deus consegui passar
e hoje eu sou bolsista lá e aí que entra
pra lhe dera eu acho que o proibida por
lei é pra quem não conhece é um programa
de desenvolvimento de líderes que vem
com uma pegada de vamos discutir debater
o cenário atual brasileiro com jovens e
com pc pessoas referência nas grandes
áreas de política social economia
educação e hoje está chamando as pessoas
mais referência de todas essas áreas
para discutir com esses jovens e
objetivo é criar projetos de soluções e
melhorias empreendimentos que ajude a
transformar a sociedade brasileira
uma coisa que eu sempre pensava muito é
o seguinte nós achamos uma faculdade de
excelência é muito bacana
as pessoas discutem pouco né reclamou
muito e reclamava não muda
não adianta a gente sair daqui agora e
para o bar bebê comemorar no happy hour
e não começar a fazer nada e entrar
naquela discussão no partido a partido b
então por que a gente realmente num não
traz o debate para alto nível e não só
numa questão de vaidade intelectual de
só de bater e as pessoas presentes aqui
saírem daqui de uma forma mais clara com
relação ao assunto vamos criar projetos
para impactar as pessoas e eu tenho
muito orgulho que eu falo que nós
tivemos dois mil inscritos é o primeiro
ano do programa 37 selecionados somente
e começamos semana passada hoje teve o
programa também acontece aos sábados na
cidade de são paulo e foi um grande
desafio ficar indo e voltando é rio de
janeiro são paulo até o programa
acontecer
e de onde vem essa idéia do programa é
uma vez assim eu ajudei a dá-la pela
fundação uma palestra junto como nizan
guanaes e alguns outros bolsistas
semanais é um empresário do ramo de
comunicação e ele falou muito que as
pessoas que poderiam estar fazendo não
estão fazendo sabe as pessoas que estão
poderia estar realizando coisas
sofisticadas a níveis de gerar impacto
não estou fazendo e naquele momento me
sentindo de veja que eu fui sempre muito
ajudado cara tem que fazer alguma coisa
e com o meu sonho a longo prazo é atuar
na política brasileira então por que não
agora começar a movimentar as moléculas
começa a incentivar jovens a se engajar
nesse movimento também
e não estou falando em entrar na
política estou falando partido não sou
filiado a partido os filiados nada mas
eu acredito que hoje eu tô fazendo a
minha parte e aqui essa galera do
prolibras 2016
hoje eu estava aqui tal várias vezes
assim ligando pra lá para são paulo lá
pra cidade e como estão as coisas e é
muito bacana ter tem uma galera tão tão
interessante querendo fazer coisas para
mudar o nosso país
e aí tem uma frase que é muito bacana é
que vivemos por fé e não pelo pir
vivemos e aí no brasil que eu quero
viver
eu quero ver menos desigualdade mais
profissionalismo e - nepotismo no brasil
eu quero viver eu quero inclusão
diversidade e - segregação no brasil que
eu quero viver
eu não quero xenofobia interna onde a
gente valoriza tanto aquele que vem de
fora e falam outra língua e agentes e
grega uma outra pessoa que vem de uma
região um pouco mais afastada e ocupa às
vezes as comunidades como por exemplo lá
no rio de janeiro então acho que esse
brasil que nós deveríamos devemos querer
pra nós mesmos entender que nós que
somos o que fazemos parte dessa mudança
e aí eu acho que o brasil não quero
viver também tem mais bruno fabiane
setur rafaela principal lu oeb
ana bispo e mas vocês também que estão
aqui hoje dedica uma parte do seu tempo
para tentar é desenvolver coisas e
aprender e se inspirar e com idéias e
projetos e gente tem uma frase que eu
levo pra minha vida que é do abraão
lincon que é um cara que eu admiro muito
que a pecar pelo silêncio quando se
deveria protestar transforma homens em
covardes
então hoje nós temos duas atitudes ao
sairmos daqui uma é simplesmente
alimentar da nossa vaidade intelectual
essas idéias e conversavam somente com
os amigos ou então começar a mexer os
pauzinhos para começar a fazer alguma
coisa para ajudar a melhorar a sociedade
então acredito que minha parte estou
fazendo e espero ver vocês junto nessa
juntos nessa caminhada que deus nos
abençoe muito obrigado irmãos